[Music]
in original chicken news chicken right
here say something submitted by Joe
Simon a local California restaurant was
caught using reheated Popeyes Chicken on
their $13 sandwiches I heard about the
thought you would say I way Neil I don't
think there's anything wrong with this
but go on do it what if you own and then
you hear someone's profiting and
charging more than your buying from me
but they're making more money but I'm
not greedy yeah this one it's like
there's two sides either you're like
what's wrong or what the [ __ ] so here's
here's what's happening to your house so
there's this this restaurant called
sweet Dixie kitchen in Long Beach
California oh it's right around the
corner sweet niche yeah so it all
started with this one yelp review they
gave them a one-star in all caps I just
read it to here okay there's a little
asian girl - no it's a it's it's a it's
a white dad he looks like a - the
chicken they use is from Popeyes all
caps
okay back to regular now before my
friends and I got seated we saw them
quickly bring in two large boxes of
Popeyes to the kitchen I wanted to
believe that this was just a snack for
the workers but alas it was not yes I
ordered the chicken and waffles to see
whether or not they were serving Popeyes
to their customers I thought that
chicken tasted suspiciously like Popeyes
and was also rather stale I kindly asked
our waiter how they cooked their fried
chicken after checking he admitted that
they do in fact use Popeyes the waffle
is also hard as rocks
the manager compensated us for the
entire meal three out of the five of us
either thought their food was okay or
enjoyed it if you're considering having
any chicken dish here then just go to
Popeyes
so he responds that's crazy that they
weren't even discreet about it they just
went through the front door yeah so this
is yeah we use Bob pies
even the waiter said yeah yeah yeah
today
yesterday's can see yeah so Kimberly the
business owner here she responded to
Tyler which is the Yelp reviewers look
she stops herself in a lot of her
sentences okay what damn right there we
go get ready for hi Tyler
look here [ __ ] hi Tyler we
proudly serve Popeyes spicy tenders the
best fried chicken anywhere and from New
Orleans which are delivered twice a day
we also in case you need to know by our
gumbo from a friend who sells it at a
local farmers market and our Jam which
we used to make here we were introduced
to a woman from Alabama who now sells
the most wonderful jams and as it has
always been our goal to feature local
food and guest chefs here we promote
usually small batch local producers in
our menu
the exception is Popeyes we can't fry
this location oh and it's the Fried
Chicken I love so much and I ate a ton
of it in the ATL so I serve it we also
don't grow our own veggies we purchased
those and if we run out of our own
slow-cooked pork in order to keep our
menu intact I will order a batch of
carnitas from the best place in Long
Beach we don't mill our own flour and as
we don't own a mill or wheat farm and
that cake is made by our prep cook who
makes cakes for private clients just FYI
oh so whatever to you and your little
review like it was some great exposure
and whatever to you dude we do what we
do and bring Longbeach the best food
mostly made here but we always get by
with a little help from our friends and
we don't want it any other way
Kim Sanchez si you know what the problem
is Oh attitude that offensive about yeah
the owner - what like she's been outed
and she's like well actually what
restaurant grows their own best about
replies fun cuz that's pretty funny it's
just so funny because like that's like
the most childish way to respond to
somebody right whatever to you it's like
when somebody catches you in a lie right
and viewed somebody bold-faced lies to
you that hurts you it's like well why'd
you lie it's like what you never lied
before you know people always do that in
an argument where they bring something
up that's completely arbitrary to what's
happening now and that's what that was
you know oh I'm not a caveman over here
with the stone doing this yeah is it my
fault that I'm not churning my own
butter coulda just said hey man we like
using Popeye's Chicken yep yeah game
over yeah the only point that made sense
was sorry we haven't been able to get a
fryer in yet but we also wanted to
provide chicken and waffles cuz we loved
the dish yeah yeah or she could have
been like hey um yeah thanks for you
know putting that out there sorry you
felt deceived or whatever we'll put it
we'll put it on her Minnie yeah that's a
thing that is it on the baby so that's
the main argument from people that are
against are against this cuz they're
saying like well if you're so proud of
it why don't you just plaster it on your
menu because apparently they do there's
no transparency cuz all the restaurants
do that yeah Starbucks used to say we
probably serve Cheesecake Factory
patients or whatever I could do that all
the time we use King's Hawaiian bread
for our sliders yeah but they they're
saying um that they do do that for their
coffee apparently they do say like they
because they have a team with them like
it's a cuz like like Cinnabon you could
go to gas stations and then oh say
Cinnabon and they have the logo and then
you can get some you know cinnamon bread
that she has contacted the franchise
owner of the Popeyes where she gets the
chicken but that she hasn't been able to
get a Rasheeda get permission little
shoes like that yeah that's pretty much
what she's saying is that she didn't get
official permission but she's still
using it and like her her argument as
well is that she yes she got Popeyes
Chicken but she Cree
did something completely different so I
can see that by making it into a
sandwich or the waffle like chicken and
waffles so that's not making into
something difficult chicken and waffles
you take the chicken and you put it on
which David oh she wrote this like
continuing to defend it and she was WOW
really like after Yelp she went on
Facebook and you ground your own [ __ ]
grain do you grow your own cows yeah you
can grow count Oga you know we don't
sleep when I do joke does buddy it
wasn't really funny through is it for
real funny no no legit nothing sarcastic
I liked it yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] do you grow
your own children no he gave me the
Craig you can't take it away and you
never get credit for anything nope it
she's a [ __ ] put down as to continue
[Laughter]
where'd you come from you said earlier
oh that's the true love me did so
anyways dammit anymore
don't do it at the track don't do it you
can do it she said it like the [ __ ] it
get out girl like just do it it's
awesome yeah so a lot of people were
also pointing out the fact that in there
about me section of this restaurant they
changed it so originally this is what it
says everything is made here right down
to our bacon jam and sriracha sour cream
sauce stay local stay happy and always
eat well and then they changed it what
if there's a local [ __ ] Popeyes
it's still local well they're not making
it there that like
at that location so this is what's the
new one says we staple to our southern
routes big flavor with conscious
healthier cooking methods parentheses
except that darn chicken in dog's
affection we are the home of the biscuit
way to determine that we also use for
the baker occasionally lol those
delicious sandwiches on our awesome
biscuits or a waffle sandwich or
award-winning pastry or it's made with
love with the bottle water dance we love
she talks too much scratch right now she
writes too much do you guys are missing
love the key parts no it'sit's it's
losing me cuz it's like a [ __ ] novel
all she needs to say is check it out we
make everything here no you're missing
the party chains which is it's made with
love with the best ingredients we love
most from scratch keep yeah yeah so they
changed it up so she wants people to
focus on guess what guys that's one
thing but there's all this other stuff
that we do because you're the the issue
with this is like if you guys if anybody
doesn't understand is number one this is
not proper advertising and there's no
transparency in the original thing and
on top of that too if you're going to
say that your restaurant is a place
where you're sourcing from other places
then you're not a restaurant you're a
co-op those are two different things
does that mean coop coop is like a place
where other people get this other stuff
and you're just a distributor for it you
killed so I don't have any problems with
her selling Popeyes that's cool or what
about the fact that she's charging 13
bucks over what she come but she
probably should have done is just didn't
you know say chicken is from Popeye yeah
that's it the only fun third parties the
false advertisements people were just
shot because they think they're gonna
get chicken that's made their yeah
they're expecting and then there's no
chicken from there it's Popeye's Chicken
imagine if I've made Joe Donald's right
but all I did was just bought everything
from McDonald hock and brought it over
and the name goes with everything Joe
Mallya Joe Donald jabber ki jagah Ragini
Joe plies and Joseph eyes yeah
then someone it's the original 100 Joe
pies got it so someone posted this yelp
review one star would you like to read
you know what's funny
a lot of the 88 Yelpers couldn't figure
out that it was popeyes chicken for the
last several years somehow this place
made it with four stars and so many
reviews hahaha unreal
what's even more unreal is that the
owner it's okay to reheat and reserve
Popeyes too funny I know they misspelled
the owner wrote it because there's
pointing out the fact that I mean it's a
pretty good point
Jonah is just like oh yeah I'm cool with
reheating up something that's not even
made here and then like giving them like
stale chicken too yeah like like once
again it's just a transparency party
they should have known it was from
Popeyes and then people wouldn't have
bought it but she liked the sales from
it she liked what people were saying
about it so she didn't to tell people
and that's a fact so she lied to your
customer base or she could have said
those from Popeyes and people what about
it you know like if someone was like yo
it's a spot down the street making
sandwiches at a Popeye's Chicken I'm
like that sounds live okay yeah like yo
they're making you know they're making
[ __ ] I don't know chicken sandwiches
out of out of Church's Chicken now all
right right yeah it's like you know what
to expect so that makes you want to go
more yeah I don't want to be tricked
mm-hmm-hmm was it that the most
interesting you've ever heard in your
whole entire life I don't even know what
you guys just talked about but anyways
please subscribe for more random videos
more funny content and more ha ha ha
Cooper in your pants stuff go ahead
subscribe and for more videos right now